großbritannien steuert auf den harten
drexhage das wissen sie es bleibt leider
kaum noch zeit für verhandlungen und das
befürchtete szenario wird immer
wahrscheinlicher
trotzdem ist premier ministerin may beim
parteitag ihrer konservativen tories
diese woche ja geradezu beschwingt zum
rednerpult getänzelt zu abbas dancing
queen
ja ja das war nicht schlecht war nicht
oder das kann man kann man machen vor
allem was natürlich eine selbstironische
anspielung wolfraum inzwischen einen ruf
hat als legendär schlechte tänzerin
neulich beim afrika besuch hat sie ja im
prinzip so was wie den tanz zum rexit
aufgeführt
[Musik]
schön dass der schiller co
schüler
das gilt ja als lösbar
kurz danach trat sie in afrika zwölf
wochen am stück geregnet
eigentlicher star des parteitags der
tories war aber natürlich ihr feind ihr
konkurrent boris johnson
ex-außenminister und völlig
durchgeknallter braig sieht hardliner ja
meine der mann hat gar kein amt mehr
gilt aber als kommender herrscher der
insel
er findet frau mails pläne den scheck
us-plan ich zitiere geisteskrank was aus
seinem mund irgendwie lustig klingt aber
aus seinem mund klingt ja fast alles
lustig die eu erinnert mich ein wenig an
schlechten seite unterhosen angekommen
solche die an einigen stellen zu eng
sind in viel zu engen und an anderen
dann wiederum die geradezu gefährlicher
weise zu weit denke ich nicht darüber
nachdenkt vertrauen sie mir führt
nirgendwo hin
er führt nirgendwo hin die braig sind
befürworter haben null plan für den
ausstieg 0
sie sind mehrfach beim lügen erwischt
worden und lügen jetzt umso dreister
weiter als außenminister hat die eu
gerade in dieser woche als gefängnis
bezeichnet und mit der sowjetunion
verglichen eu nur weil sie nach einem
austritt nicht mehr den vollen zugang zu
unseren binnenmarkt hätten ihr wolltet
doch raus für diese vögel braucht man
inzwischen einen exorzisten freunde
ernsthaft ja ist ja nicht übertrieben
hier engländer die tante angela erklärt
euch das noch mal wie sehr sehr doofen
kindern
aber es gibt eben auch ein paar maßstäbe
und einer dieser maßstäbe ist dass man
nicht zum binnenmarkt gehören kann wenn
man nicht teil des binnenmarktes ist ja
genau engländer nur wenn man im
binnenmarkt ist ist man im binnenmarkt
kapiert gott komm ich mache noch
einfacher guck mal das hier ist meine
neue boris johnson sockenpuppen guck mal
und das hier ist die eu ja jetzt ist der
bau ist drinnen draußen
aber hier habe ich ja kein markt mehr
aber du wolltest doch raus als die
freizeit sag mal
es hat keinen sinn
es bringt ja nichts die meisten von
denen sind argumenten gar nicht mehr
zugänglich es ist eine insel mit
begrenzter platz wenn man sie füllt ohne
kontrolle darüber
womit wird sie sinken sie wird
untergehen ja das ist fakt jede insel
hat ein bestimmtes fassungsvermögen ja
wenn du dann nur einen dicken polnischen
klempner zu viel ein wandern lässt dann
kippt mich nur die stimmung dann soll
der ganze laden ab das ist schlecht
schwerkraft auf kritisch
dass das müssen wir natürlich ganz
realistisch den ratschläge aus
deutschland wollen die briten als
allerletztes aber einen mann hält das
nicht ab
gernot hassknecht janofske erklärt den
hang ländern was nach dem exit passieren
wird in 150 sekunden
sehr geehrte engländer die ihr brit
meine lieben sommersprossige freunde
die uhr tickt so clock is ticking am 29
märz 2009 10 um punkt elf uhr abends
seid ihr raus dass ihr geht aber ja es
steht mir bis hier schön was los ist
blues diese arroganz gut bin aber es
wäre womöglich ein wirtschaftliches
desaster
und als hank das glaube ich wüsste nicht
warum wenn wir die besten produkte in
der welt produzieren
dann werden diese auch andere länder
weiter mit kaufen ein
das muss wohl der berühmte britische
humor sein
dieses widerliche mir dass man mit
messer und gabel trinken muss ein
händler
ihr habt eine acht um negative
handelsbilanz ihr seid import süchtig
allein könnt ihr euch nicht malen wollte
schmieren
das belegte pausenbrot das sandwich ist
in gefahr käse aus irland dänischer
schinken gurken aus holland und tomaten
aus spanien gibt euch doch einfach ein
bisschen von eurem berühmte sich drauf
und schmeckt kein mit im letzten jahr
importierte großbritannien 3000 sperma
spenden von der größten europäischen
samenbank in dänemark unfassbar tv zum
selber wechseln
damit ist feierabend wir schneiden euch
von der stromversorgung ab mit wikinger
gene dann müsst ihr euch wieder aus
eurem eigenen bedienen
dank britischen notenbank chefs koste
der bread sit-in durchschnittshaushalt
jetzt schon 900 pfund pro jahr und für
alle denen das zu kompliziert ist stelle
ich den weiteren verlauf des packs it
hier mal symbolisch mit einem
doppeldeckerbus
[Musik]
in diesem sinne gute fahrt oder auf
englisch gut vater
[Applaus]
[Musik]